moving on now to washington and a major
decision by the supreme court blocking
the biden administration's temporary ban
on evictions it's a victory for
landlords and property owners and it
could spell trouble for people who have
struggled to pay their rent during the
pandemic
zhang is at the supreme court for suija
good morning
good morning tony and good morning to
everybody the white house said it is
disappointed by this ruling which is a
blow to president biden the result of
the high court's conservative majority
and certainly one that he himself saw
coming in a 6-3 decision the court
blocked the biden administration from
enforcing a temporary ban on evictions
that was put in place because of the
coronavirus pandemic ending protections
for millions of americans who have not
been able to pay the rent the court said
in an unsigned opinion the cdc has
exceeded its authority to issue a
nationwide moratorium on evictions
calling it a breathtaking an
unprecedented exercise of power by a
federal agency and if a federally
imposed eviction moratorium is to
continue congress must specifically
authorize it the court's three liberals
dissented citing the rise of the coven
19 delta variant the administration has
vigorously called on state and local
governments to adopt their own eviction
measures and distribute existing funds
to help keep families in their homes but
just yesterday the treasury department
revealed that only 5.1 billion dollars
of the more than 46 billion in rental
assistance already approved by congress
had gone out through the end of july now
earlier this month the president
acknowledged that a new ban may not be
constitutional but he said it was worth
a shot to help millions of americans
vlad
all right we do change for us we thank
you very much